protesters in the Haitian Capital Porter
Prince angry at the idea that foreign
troops could once again be deployed to
their country
we are making President Biden remember
the promise he made when he knelt in
front of the Haitian community in the
United States he asked them to vote for
him so that the situation in Haiti would
change but they did not vote for him to
have a president who was assassinated
Haiti has a troubled history but the
situation has rarely been as Grave as
this it's a place crippled by violence
and disease
cholera is spreading more than 20 people
have died many more have contracted the
disease there is an economic food and
fuel crisis too the UN says 19 000
people in the capital are living in
famine conditions there are shortages of
fresh water some hospitals are preparing
to close and the main fuel Depot is
blockaded by armed gangs which roam the
streets of the city that's why the U.N
Secretary General says the only solution
is a strike force made up of
international troops and police
in the present circumstances we need an
armed action to release the port and to
allow for humanitarian Corridor to be
established
gang that's blockading the Fuel Depot is
led by this man Jimmy Chelsea known by
his nickname barbecue who Al Jazeera
filmed earlier in the year he and other
gang leaders could soon be subject to
Security Council sanctions
the U.S is drawing up two draft Security
Council resolutions one to authorize an
international Force the other to Target
gang leaders like Chelsea
he is directly responsible for the
devastating fuel shortage that is
crippling the country
by passing this resolution we would take
concrete actions to hold him and so many
other violent criminals to account
there are still many unanswered
questions the U.S is drawing up the two
resolutions one of which would create
the international Force but would it
contribute to it and which other
countries would do so it's also not
clear how other members of the security
Council will respond to this idea
already China and Russia are expressing
reservations
the view of the Haitian people is also
important the protests that took place
on the streets of Port-au-Prince at
exactly the same time the security
Council was meeting may prove sobering
for some a number of people were
carrying Russian flags as they protested
a new international intervention they
even brought a coffin a symbol they said
of what will happen to foreign troops if
they're deployed here James Bays Al
Jazeera at the United Nations